I am sitting here with one of my
absolute favorite people the hilarious
comedian but also just one of my
favorite philosophers I don't know
I don't either you're a trip thank you
you're like a genius on any topic I love
hearing you're like a jukebox ah but
instead of quarters you put in drugs
yeah please
this is just something I don't see
enough of on late-night for my taste I
don't necessarily even want to have like
a hilarious conversation I want to get
into it let's do it can we yeah where
are the drugs how are you doing me I
haven't seen you in ages
I'm doing great are you what are you
doing well I was gonna ask are you doing
drugs do you go ahead and weird hippie
trips definitely doing drugs definitely
going on weird hippie trips for sure I
just must story my life you've been on
my podcast twice I've been on NORs twice
I think our conversations are some of
the most favorite conversation I've ever
had in my life here one of the things
you said that changed my life was the
thing about it's like we're astronauts
traveling and it's sort of like if you
were an astronaut that got sent to a
distant distant planet and the amount of
time it took you to get there words how
many billion years there are between the
Big Bang in this moment right now and to
imagine that after that long journey
you're gonna spend the sixty years you
get to be in between nothingness working
in some crappy job wearing a noose
covered in polka-dots you know people
have to put on ties terrible and you
said to me you were like if you were in
this ship your body yes to tear it
deteriorating yes slowly yeah wouldn't
you want to touch taste lick smell
everything you could yeah most
everything you could some things avoid
like you diapers for example leave that
out of the little in a smell or yeah
like a diaper
I don't understand when hippies and the
60s and Enlightenment and Eastern
philosophy started to become like a joke
like it was something that we all just
kind of moved away from and now we're
all you know just drinking soda pop and
watching it in that porn and all this
sort of stuff when we used to have when
we used to be striving for like
community it feels like it was like shut
down somehow well it's the same thing
that happen with Christianity which is
that people started associating
fundamentalist Christians like the
Phelps family with the message of
Christianity instead of going directly
into the message of Christianity and
realizing this is the most psychedelic
love-filled revolutionary philosophy
that exists on planet Earth the same
thing happened it's like people see you
know they started you know the I think
the hippies started getting into math or
something and you know they the whole
thing kind of fell apart and you realize
it like no you have to take showers
sometimes man you can't just right
there's like a whole other side to this
there has to be balance and that's why I
love that you know in the East they
refer to all the religions and all the
different philosophies as vehicles you
know when you say something's a vehicle
you're you're saying this is a way to
get from one point to the next it's not
it's not where you're supposed to sit
for example if you and I Drive to the
beach once we get to the beach we don't
stay in the car that would be weird
we're like well we're here let's just
warm the whim there roll the window you
get out you go to the beach yeah you
love Ramdas yeah he studied with
Maharaja neem Karoli Baba yeah that is a
fascinating story I love the stories you
know about him this is a guy that tell
whichever one you want what happened was
you know he was at this party and he
took too many mushrooms we've all been
there and then he went and then he cuz
you like what did I just do
why didn't I just drink beer
I didn't want to dissolve in the
universal consciousness I wanted to ask
a couple of good conversations and go
home no we're about to talk to God this
is like another person I'm really into
right now is this teacher jack Kornfield
who's this incredible Buddhist teacher
and he's so good at articulating
Buddhism in a really simple way and um
you know he just says just sit down for
10 minutes and let yourself feel for a
second like you know so many people are
just never letting themselves feel it's
so funny that you say that cuz that's
something I've been going through lately
where my friends will be like I have a
hard time meditating I'm like no one
wants to meditate now it's the wrong
word
it makes your dick go inside your body
you know I when I meditate I have a bell
that I hit and I just realized a couple
days ago like why am i hitting this Bell
like I have no reason to hit it I'll
spring about what am i doing I know what
you're doing because this is something
also we've talked about is that we're
hungry for ritual all right
we really are I'm realizing the older I
get the more I go away from my
traditional faith the more I start to
understand that then this is from
Richard Rohr who I think you would love
all of those rituals are dress
rehearsals for the true experience which
is constant communion oh wow oh we
should talk about something else they
did this on Kimmel TV is getting really
cool man it used to be that you just
talked about golfer baby or something
now we can talk about this don't you
thank you so much yeah you Pete they do
it again oh I think about those old
Letterman shows you know when he was
really early and it it have you know
you're Harvey Pekar and just like
strange dudes and I mean that in the
highest compliment way I just think
that's such a fun element of love
anytime man and Pete
can we please hang yeah when there
aren't cameras yes I miss you man I
guess you do Game of Thrones come watch
Game of Thrones with me you kidding
winter's coming
whoa like is she the hot one way she's
hot she is the mother of dragons Pete
Holmes oh I'm sorry
Khaleesi the mother of dragons you bear
a dragon I wouldn't want to go in there
she would actually lay an egg
technically you wouldn't a dragon
wouldn't flatter your that'd be
incredible
I'd be incredible why didn't they
do that in Game of Thrones that would
have been the most-watched episode of
all time I'll just watch it again and
again and again to watch a dragon
explode covered in barbarian placenta do
you have friends like this